we're taking a look at how to get a 2020
Honda Pilot started if the key fob dies
so I've taken the battery out of this
key fob to demonstrate as you can see
none of the buttons are working if I try
to start the vehicle as I normally would
it's not going to
start and if I keep trying to start it
I'm going to get a message on the dash
saying to start hold remote near start
button so that's what we're do we'll
take our key fob and just hold it up to
the stop start button
you'll hear a beep and then you'll see
this glow solid and then you'll be able
to start the vehicle as
normal and then you'll be able to drive
the vehicle as normal and you'll just
need to replace the battery in the key
fob as soon as you can